et l'idée ce qui m'amusait c'était de
comprendre pourquoi le savon de
Marseille et de Marseille
Jamy gourmand
revanche votre premier livre après 25
ans de carrière scientifique comment ça
se fait que vous avez écrit tous les
exemplaires vous-même
25 ans de passeur je ne suis pas
scientifique un vulgarisateur oui au
sens noble du terme évidemment alors ça
s'appelle mon tour de France des
curiosités naturelles et scientifiques
alors c'est publié chez Stock les
dessins sont de votre épouse
c'est 16 voyages à travers l'Hexagone
vous vouliez raconter l'émotion que
génère les sites et sur chaque site vous
nous racontez une histoire alors
pourquoi le soleil rougit quand il se
lève par exemple voilà bah ça c'est le
début du livre en fait c'est une
histoire c'est quelque chose que j'ai
vécu très tôt dans mon enfance parce que
je suis originaire de Vendée et quand
j'étais môme et bien j'allais à la pêche
avec mon père et mes frères et on
partait très tôt le matin et quand on
parle du du soleil qui rougit on pense
très souvent au coucher de soleil et moi
le truc qui m'a marqué depuis mon
enfance c'est pas le coucher de soleil
c'est le lever du soleil c'est les aubes
vendéennes les auberen parce que les
choix on regarde vers l'est et non pas
vers l'ouest et le lever du soleil c'est
pas que la couleur c'est aussi des
odeurs c'est d'autres sensations et
c'est ça que j'avais envie de raconter
pourquoi les volcans français peuvent se
réveiller le mine de rien ils peuvent
vraiment se réveiller même les miss se
réveillent oui on considère en général
c'est pas moi qui le dit ce sont les les
scientifiques que j'ai rencontrés les
volcanologues que j'ai rencontré qui qui
me l'ont expliqué qui me racontait en
fait on considère qu'un volcan est
définitivement éteint quand il n'est pas
entre en éruption pendant 10000 ans on
n'y est pas or certains exactement
certains volcans d'Auvergne c'est
exactement les les éruptions les plus
récentes date de 6 7000 ans vous dites
partir d'une émotion mais quand vous
êtes devant un champ de betterave
en Champagne quelle est l'émotion
elle vient pas elle vient pas du champ
lui-même mais quand vous découvrez cette
cette activité cette culture que vous
regardez cette plante vous dites mais
comment cette plante a-t-elle pu
révolutionner notre agriculture cette
plante est véritablement même si elle
est très laide elle est magique c'est la
plante sur la planète qui est capable de
produire le meilleur rendement de sucre
et ce qui est génial quand quand vous
quand vous essayez de comprendre comment
fonctionne
et bien vous apercevez que il fait du
glucose il fait du fructose et c'est un
véritable laboratoire il mélange les
deux il fait du saccharose et voilà mais
c'est important de regarder notre nature
comme ceci parce qu'avec tout ce qui se
passe en ce moment où on nous annonce un
futur très hypothétique avec des
milliers millions d'espèces qui sont en
train de disparaître si on veut bien
comprendre pourquoi ces espèces sont
importantes qu'elles soient animal ou
végétales il faut comprendre comment
elle fonctionne pédophilie le scandale
de la betterave
c'est un peu c'est un peu comme la pomme
de terre la pomme de terre de
parementier d'ailleurs alors ce qui est
top en fait dans votre bouquin c'est
qu'il y a des chapitres sur des
curiosités régionales
l'unceste dans le Nord qui est très très
bien traité l'alcoolisme en Bretagne et
les talons compensés dans le sud et bien
j'y penserai pour le prochain volume là
pour Marseille vous avez hésiter entre
le savant et la kalachnikov je préfère
le savon voilà mais les deux font le
ménage la soude la soude qui est à
l'origine une plante également l'idée ce
qui m'amusait c'était de comprendre
pourquoi le savon de Marseille et de
Marseille et en fait ça ne pouvait pas
ça ne pouvait se faire
en Dessoude aussi beaucoup à Marseille
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mon tour de France dit que j'étais
naturel et scientifique chez stocke fait
aussi côté jardin tous les samedis sur
France 3 à 15h15 et vos documents le
monde de Jamy sur France 3 tout va bien
finalement pour le moment tout va très
bien très beau tout va bien très bien et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu